- Hello everybody and welcome
to our last refugee program
seminar for the semester.
So today we have the pleasure
of having Professor Sandra Rozo,
who is gonna be talking about
the Brothers or Invaders
and How Crisis-Driven Migrants
Shape Voting Behavior.
Professor Rozo is a
development and labor economist
and she works at the
Marshall School of Business
at the University of Southern California
and her work focuses on firm decision,
forced migration, diversity and crime.
So please join me welcoming Professor Rozo
for the seminar.
- Thank you very much for the invitation.
I'm very, very excited to be here.
This is a wonderful program
and I am very honored
for the invitation.
So the paper that I will
present today is a paper
that in a nutshell, to kind
of give you an overview
of what I will be talking
about, it evaluates the effects
that Venezuelan migration
has had on voting behaviors.
And this is going to be
joint work with Juan Vargas
from Universidad del Rosario.
So before I begin, I just
wanted to kind of bring
this quote from The Economist.
It was published in
2018 to kind of motivate
what I will be talking about.
So it says, "The fear of immigration
is poisoning Western politics.
Donald Trump owes his job to it and Brexit
would not be happening without it.
Strident nationalist
wield the power in Italy,
Hungary, Poland and Austria,
and have gained influence elsewhere.
So basically a couple of years ago,
there was already this idea
that migration in many cases
is used as a weapon in
the political arena.
And so this is one of the ideas
that we want to explore in this paper.
So just to motivate what
we think this is relevant.
I wanted to talk
a little bit about bring
forced displacement to context.
So forced displacement has
been increasing dramatically,
as of 2019 we have
almost 80 million people
who have been forcibly displaced.
And just to kind of
give you like a context
or put more context into this number,
this is the size of almost two California.
So we're talking about a very large number
of individuals here,
and most of the migrants
are hosted in developing
nations, which is not surprising
because those are the neighbors
of other conflict countries.
So why do we think that forced migrants
to serve a different analysis?
So forced migration has very
different characteristics
than economic migration.
So for one, forced migrants tend to arrive
in very large numbers.
They are all going through
very vulnerable journeys
and they arrive with no assets
at all or very few assets.
Typically forced migrants tend
to be disproportional represented
by women and children.
And lastly, they face large uncertainty.
So when they're making their decisions,
they don't have a current clear situation
of whether they will be allowed to stay
or they will be moving again or going back
and for that, the decisions that they make
might be very different from the ones made
by an economic migrant.
So to kind of tell you a
little bit of what is known
about the impacts that forced migration
and migration in generally
has had on voting behaviors.
There has been very, let's
say robust recent work
on trying to measure what are the impacts
that higher forced migration
has had on the support
for right-wing ideologies
and political participation.
And in general, most of these papers
are focused on developed
countries and they show
that when the forced
migration inflows increase,
there is a surge or
right-wing support increases,
and there is kind of mixed evidence
onto what happens with voters turnout.
Some papers find is positive
and some papers find
that that is negative.
So what are we going to do in this paper?
What we're going to do is first try to see
if this is true also for
our developing countries.
So what happens in a developing country
when you have a large
surge of forced migration,
what happen with voting behaviors?
And then we're gonna explore
three different mechanisms.
So one of them is what we call
the socio-economic mechanism,
which is basically trying to see
whether the economic impacts
that forced migration
might be having might be
driving this voting effects
or these political
effects that we observe.
And there is a couple
more which are cultural
and electoral manipulation
that I will explain
in a second exactly how they are defined.
So although there is a lot of
evidence on trying to measure
how forced migration
impacts voting behaviors,
especially for the northern countries
of the world the US, Europe.
There is quite a debate on
what is driving this mechanism.
So, as I mentioned earlier,
there's probably three main mechanisms
that we're gonna explore in this paper.
One of it is what we call
the socio-economic hypothesis
or the economic hypothesis which says
basically that migrants react
in their voting behaviors
to migration because migration
creates economic effects,
which could be positive
or negative in general,
we're pointing to negative effects.
That's what most of the
papers actually find.
For example, migration
might be increasing crime
or migration might reduce
job opportunities for locals
and this is why they basically react
with more antipathy towards migration.
Another different
hypothesis is that migration
basically creates this
in-group and out-group tensions
in a way such that the nationals
of a country feel threatening
their cultural views relative
to the migration or the
migrants that are coming in.
And so that's another hypothesis.
There's one however, we're only
gonna touch on tangentially
because it's really hard to prove
that this is actually driving our effects.
And the last one, which I
think is our main contribution
and which we think is pretty new,
is that in many contexts
political parties use
the migration, for example,
forced migration inflows
to associate that migration
with their competing
parties' electoral platform
in a way such that they
demonize the other party.
So let me just kind of
explain better, for example,
in Colombia, what we see is
that the right-wing parties
basically associated
the Venezuelan migration
with the Venezuelan regime and say,
if you vote for the left you
are going to become Venezuela.
And that's what we call
electoral manipulation.
So we're gonna explore whether
that is actually affecting
the effects that we have said.
So how is this presentation
gonna be structure?
I'm going to have a
structuring five parts.
So first I will briefly talk
about the Venezuelan context
for those of you who are not familiar
with it and then I'll talk
a little bit about the
data empirical strategy,
the general results of the
impacts of forced migration
on voting behaviors and then I will talk
a little bit about the mechanism.
So here is a, let's say a
short summary of the share
of Venezuelan inflows as a percentage
of a Colombian population.
So just to kind of give you an overview
how things have been going on in Colombia.
So the Venezuelan crisis
arguably begun with the election
of Hugo Chávez in 1988,
but it is only until 2016,
or if you will, 2010,
when you see an explosion
of inflows of Venezuelans to Colombia.
So what happened? Why is this happening?
So in 1998, or before this,
let me just kind of tell you
a little bit of what Venezuela
was before this crisis began,
Venezuela was a very prosperous country.
So I lived in Colombia, I'm Colombian
and I lived in Colombia
for more than 20 years
and I remember very clearly
that a lot of my family
and friends would go to Venezuela to work
in the oil companies, technology
was brought from Venezuela.
So in our view, a lot
of Colombians migrate
to live in Venezuela
because it had better social
safety nets, better education
it was a very prosperous country.
However, in 1998, Hugo
Chavez was elected president
and he was a socialist populist leader,
which introduced a lot of
constitutional amendments,
expropriations of private
property and nationalizations.
And he mainly used the oil
rents to fund all his populism.
In 2013, Nicolas Maduro was
appointed as his successor
and he strengthened all of these policies
and the crisis actually worse than there,
because he was not as fortunate as Chavez
and oil rents actually dropped.
The price of oil dropped
and the US also introduced
very drastic economic sanctions.
So kind of to give you a
little bit of an overview
of how drastic this crisis
is, between 1998 and 2018
there was a contraction of
50% of the Venezuelan GDP.
Unemployment is approximately
40% of the total labor
for it's a black country, poverty rate
is as rampant, almost 90%.
There are shortages of
food and basic services,
insecurity is very high and
there is a very large repression
to the Maduro's government.
So not surprisingly, there
has been a very large surge
of migration outside of
Venezuela to all Latin America.
So the map that I am
showing you on the right
is showing you the intensity
of migration flows.
So the darker the color, the more inflows
that country has received.
So Colombia is a primary recipient
of Venezuelan migration
flows, which by 2019,
according to the UN refugee agency
were reaching 4.5 million individuals.
And of those 4.5 million,
1.8 are registered
to be living in Colombia to stay.
So one important kind of
disclaimer about this data
is that typically this data is going
to be on the representation
of the real amount of migrants
that you would see, because of course,
there's not a very strong control
of the international borders
and a lot of migrants
are afraid to being registered
because they don't wanna be deported
or actually identified by authorities.
So what are we going to do?
So basically we're going to use data
from the electoral agency in
Colombia in two main outcome.
One is what we call
political participation
or voters turnout and the other one
is the political ideology
of each of the candidates
that are aspiring to be mayor
or presidents in the country.
So we're going to use data between 1995,
municipal annual data
between 1995 and 2018
and we're going to use data
for a six first-round
presidential elections
and five second-round
and six mayor elections.
So what is, let's say a very
hard work that we had to do
was first in identifying
the political party
of each of the candidates that posted
for any of those elections
that wanted to be elected
and then classifying
each of these candidates
on left, center or right according
to their own declarations
or by actually checking
their government's plan
or their campaign plan
and classifying them
according to these views.
So we're gonna kind of see the impacts
that voter migration
had on voters turn out,
and then on the shared votes to each
of these orientations
right, center and left.
Forced migration data is gonna come
from the Colombian Statistical Agency
and then our construction of let's say
our primary source of
identification is gonna come
from the population
censuses of 1993 and 2005.
And this is a large set of
controls that we're gonna use.
I am going to just keep this slide for now
for time efficiency.
So when we want to estimate the impacts
that Venezuela migration
has had on voting behaviors,
we faced this challenge
that of course migration is not random.
So migrants vote with their feet
and they tend to move to
municipalities that for example,
are more prosperous, where they feel safer
that presumably are more open to migrants
and that is correlated
with voting behaviors.
So what we're gonna do
is basically exploit
longitudinal variation
and we're gonna explore
two sources of variation.
One is we're gonna use
cross-sectional variation coming
from the share of Venezuelans who arrived
before the beginning of
the crisis to Colombia.
And this at the municipal level
with the early population censuses
and the temporal variation
is basically going
to come from the overall
number of individuals
that are arriving from
Venezuela to Colombia.
So the interaction of these two effects
is basically going to be what we call
the predicted Venezuelan inflows.
And it's going to try to
tell us how many migrants
we expect to see in each of
the municipalities in Colombia.
Unfortunately, this is not
going to be an ideal strategy
or fortunately as how you
see instrumental variables,
but this is going to be more
of a reduced form estimation
because there's no actual
data at the municipal level
on how many Venezuelans
live in each municipality.
And what is the assumption
that we're gonna
actually be using here is
basically that migrants tend
to move disproportionally to those areas
where they have pre-existing
networks, friends, family.
And of course, this is a very
traditional instrument used
or a proxy for migration flows used
in the migration literature.
So here is the specification
form more particularly.
So why MDT are going to
be the political outcomes
that we're examining
at the municipal level.
M stands for municipality,
D for department
and T is going to be the election year.
And then we're going to
try to see the impacts
that's our measure of
predicted Venezuelan inflows
has had on the political outcomes.
And this is coming from the instrument
that I just explained or the
variable that we created.
And we're going to control
for a lot of covariates
to kind of clean these
confounders that may be affecting
the estimates of the here
that we want to identify.
One of them is we're going to include
as much as we can baseline covariates
at the municipality level
interacted with year dummies.
The idea here is basically to see
or clean all of these stories
that may be confounding
the impacts of Venezuelan migration
on are correlated presumably
with our outcomes.
We're gonna include interactions
of department trends
and year trends or election year trends
and we're gonna include fixed effects
by election year and municipality.
So here is how we constructed specifically
the measure of predicted
Venezuelan inflow.
So it's going to be
corresponding to the interaction
of the cumulative Venezuelan
inflow to Colombia,
the overall national inflows.
This is like, let's say the
temporal variation interacted
with a municipal variation of
early Venezuelan settlements
in Colombia.
It is in 1993, which is
the last population census
before Chavez was elected in 1998.
And we're gonna just kind of scale
these over the population of
serving each municipality.
So to show you a little
bit of the validity
of these variable in truly capturing
the Venezuelan settlements
at the municipality level,
we did two exercises.
One of them is basically using
the predicted Venezuelan
inflows this proxy
that we're going to use
for Venezuelan location
and the data that we
have from the censuses
to show that indeed Venezuelans
are moving to those areas.
So on your left, you have
a map of Colombia divided
by municipality in
which we're illustrating
the predicted Venezuelan inflows in 1993
and on your right, we crossed
that figure with circles
that are larger for the
inflows that arrived
between 1993 and 2005.
So in 2005 of Venezuelan.
In 2005 we observe
another population census.
And when we have population censors,
we have the unique
opportunity to truly verify
where Venezuelans are located.
So you can see that
there is a large overlap
between both variables and
that actually the correlation
is strong and significant.
We did the same exercise.
Would we the last population censuses?
So we have three senses 1993, 2005
and 2018 during our period of analysis.
And the census of 2018,
unfortunately, does not allow us,
or we haven't gotten an access
to the specific nationality identified
but we know who's a foreigner.
The good news is that of the
whole foreigners in Colombia,
approximately 90% are Venezuela's.
So we basically also
show a similar graph here
in which we show our early
settlements of Venezuela in 1993,
and the location of foreigners in 2018.
And again, the correlation
between both variables
is very, very large.
So when you use bartik
shift-share instruments,
like the one that we constructed
there has been kind of a very big surge
of critique storage this type of variable.
So here, I'm going to kind of
talk about two main threats
that might be affecting the
validity of this variable,
but we actually talk about
more of them in our paper.
So the first one is one broad
by Goldsmith and Pinkham
in which he basically says,
for this, let's say variables
to be credible what we need to
show is that the shared part
is actually valid that it
satisfies exogeneity assumption.
And so what we're going
to do to kind of address
this is basically include a large set
of covariates observe a baseline.
And we're gonna include here
in our estimation controls
for economic growth,
measure nightlight density
for homicides, for previous conflict,
for shares of agricultural
GDP in the whole economy.
So there is a very large set
of covarietes that we're going
to include in order to kind
of account for these bias.
And we interact those with
election dummies or year dummies
to kind of non parametrically
control for variables
that may be trending in
time and driving biases
in our estimates.
And another big let's say
critique to this instruments
is that when migration
flows are consistent,
and you're trying to use
this instrument to identify
the effects of migration,
you are confounding short
and long-term effects of migration
when you run this estimates.
And this is not going to
be such a relevant concern
because the migration
from Venezuela to Colombia
is a recent shock.
It actually became endemic after 2016.
And migration from Venezuela to Colombia
or in general from any country to Colombia
was negligible before that time.
So actually Colombia
is a very close country internationally.
So how do we execute our
analysis to kind of guide you
to what I will be talking about?
We first evaluate the
effects of forced migration
on voting behaviors.
That's the first thing I'm gonna do
and then we're gonna kind of evaluate each
of the three hypothesis that I mentioned
might be driving this effects.
So first we're going to
see, is there evidence
to kind of support the idea
that there are economic effects driving
these effects that we
observe in voting behavior?
So we're gonna study
the effects of migration
on labor outcomes and on fiscal burden,
because we think those
are the two main channels
or the two main things that
are, let's say believes
that maybe driving changes
in voting behaviors,
in the individuals that live in Colombia.
Then we're gonna kind
of cause why we think
the cultural hypothesis is not really
a very strong candidate to explain
what is going on in voting behaviors
and here we're not gonna
have any empirical strategy
because there's not enough
data at the municipal level
to actually carry out this
or evaluate this hypothesis.
And then I'm gonna kind
of show you what, or talk
a little bit about this electoral
manipulation hypothesis,
why we think it's happening,
what is anecdotical
evidence existing supporting
that and we're gonna also show
you some empirical evidence
that might support why
we think this is also
an important candidate for
the effects that we observe.
Okay.
- Sandra, one question.
So when you said that you're
looking at the elections
that they have, are these
elections at the municipal level
for mayor or for the president,
or which elections are you saying?
- Oh thank you Maria Teresa
this is a good question.
So we are going to have
three levels of elections.
So this is all the municipal level.
So it's going to correspond
to the results of the election
at the municipality level,
but we're gonna analyze
the outcomes of the
presidential election first
and second round, and the mayor elections
to kind of see whether
they kind of translate
across different types of elections.
Those are the three levels
that we're gonna study.
So let me kind of show
you the results here.
So panel A is gonna show you
the presidential elections
for the first round.
So basically whether there
was more, for example,
total votes corresponds
to voters turn out here.
So it's not municipality, do we see
that more people showed up to vote
for the presidential elections
from the second round
and for the mayor elections.
So the first column in
each of these tables
or they already, if you
want, the odd columns
are going to show you the
effects without including all
of their controls for municipal
socio-economic confounders
that may be affecting our estimates
and the even comms
control for all of those.
So here are kind of the
overall interactions
that were included, for example, conflict
and violence includes a
very large set of covariates
that account for homicide
rates, conflict, threats,
robberies and each of
these group of outcomes
is kind of accounting
for each of these groups
of different threats
that we could have on our
identification strategy.
So the second or the even columns
are the ones that we think
or we view as our preferred
estimates of the effects
of Venezuelan migration.
So what do we see?
So in general, across all
the lectures we observe
that when predicted
Venezuelan inflows increase
in standard deviations, the
voter turnout increases.
This true for the first
round, for the second round
and for mayor elections.
So overall we see people tend
to go more and vote more.
And what does that translate
to in terms of support
for left, center and right-wing
political orientation?
What we see, which is very much in line
with what we observe in other countries
is that higher predicted
Venezuelan inflows
are actually reflected in lower spot
towards left-wing political identities
and more support for the right-wing.
So basically our composition of votes
from the left to the right.
And this is very robust across
both presidential elections
and for mayor elections.
One thing to kind of point out
is that for the mayor
elections, we are not able
to statistically capture
a precise effect here,
but this is related to the fact
that the last mayor elections
that we included here took place in 2015
before the real surge in
Venezuelan migration took place.
So in a new version of this paper,
we're actually going to
include the last mayor election
that just recently took place
and that might kind of allow
us to have more power to see
if this become significant.
- [Attendee 1] Sandra I'm
sorry to interrupt you.
I'm not super familiar
with the electoral system in Colombia.
So could you tell me why
the number of observations
is so different between
the different elections?
- Yes, of course. So let's see.
So for some, the main reason
basically is that in general
there seems to be a lot more information
for the presidential
elections where we observe
a lot more political
participation if you will.
In general, we should
observe kind of voting counts
for all the municipalities of the country
but for some election years
there is no data available
and that's what probably would show
the different number of observations.
How it works is basically the
presidential elections work
in a way so that when candidates go
and try to be elected
for being a president,
if one of them gets the
majority plus one votes,
then they're elected express.
If none of them gets this majority,
then they go to a run-off
and the first two candidates,
the ones that receive more
votes actually kind of compete
in a second round and whoever
gets the majority of votes
that's gonna be the winner
across the whole country.
And mayor elections are just selected
through a simple majority rule.
Whoever gets the more votes
at the municipal level is going to win.
- [Attendee 1] Okay, so the difference
between the first row and the second row
would be not every presidential
election went to a runoff?
- Ah, exactly. Yes,
yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
That's exactly right. A lot of them.
So actually I think we
have six first-round
and five second-rounds in
the period of analysis.
- [Attendee 1] Got it.
But otherwise it's a
balanced panel, so you have-
- It should be there, but as I said,
there is some municipalities
that didn't report for,
but they are not a lot, but
there is some municipalities
that did not report voting outcomes.
- And the vote is every four
years for the presidents
and for the mayors is the
same of the four years?
- It is mostly four, but at
the beginning of the period
there were some changes in the timing.
So initially was three and
then for the rest period
it was more or less four.
And this is why we have
kind of a different numbers.
So specifically we have,
let's see just quickly,
we have six first-round, five second-round
and six mayoral elections
all across this period,
1995 and 2018.
- Do they vote at the
same time for president
and for mayors?
- No. No, they don't.
So there are other elections
going on in Colombia,
but we decided not to work
in those because the classification
of the parties becomes more complicated.
A lot of for example,
congressional candidates
did not have a very clear
agenda that will allow us,
or enable us to kind of classify
them as either center, left or right,
but they have conflicted
policies that made it very hard
for us to make a clear classification
of their political orientation
and so that's why we decided just to stay
with this three elections.
All right, so in general, what we found
is that whenever the predictive
Venezuelan inflows increase
in one standard deviation,
we see across all of the elections
so we examine larger
political participation,
lower participate, or no longer support
towards the left-wing political ideologies
and larger towards right-wing.
And just to kind of give you an overview
of how large these effects are.
The main support for the left
for the first round presidential elections
was zero point ten.
And the effect that we're
observing when we increase
our measure of predictive
Venezuelan inflows
in one standard deviation
is a change we observe
a reduction of 0.9 percentage points.
In other words, this is a 10% deviation
from the mean support for
left-wing political ideology.
So these are large impacts.
And it is important to
kind of take into account
that since the support for left
is not that large in Colombia
we're talking about very,
very important changes.
So before I move on to talk
a lot about the mechanisms
I wanted to kind of
mention two robustness test
that we kind of run to test
whether this was actually robust,
these effects that I just showed you.
So one was that we, yeah.
- We have a question before
you do that which is,
if the right-wing in Colombia
has a strong anti-immigration?
- Oh, great question.
Let me just kinda talk about
this in a couple of slides.
I'm going to on and talk about this,
but no, the short answer is no.
I will talk about that in a second.
I will have a slide of that.
So I don't want to lose a lot of time
in this robustness test
but basically what we did
is we had a lot of concerns about the fact
that maybe the departments
or the municipalities
that were located in the
border with Venezuela
had a different behavior.
Basically they were more
pro-migrant or less pro-migrant
because they see or have
more exposure to migrants.
And so for that what we did is we run
our estimates excluding
different departments
of the country, one at a time
and we run everything again,
and we find very robust
effects of everything
that I've showed you.
Another thing that we did is we say, okay,
maybe this instrument or this
variable is not a good proxy
of Venezuelan migration so
let's use a different one.
What if we use just distance
to the main border crossing locations
in the Colombia-Venezuelan border.
And for that, we calculated the distance
of each municipality to each
of these border crossings
and we ran everything again,
and the results are very, very similar.
In fact, we actually found that
there is a large correlation
between the variable that we're using
and the distance to the border,
so that the results are
also very, very similar.
Okay, so now we're gonna
move on to try to see
what could be driving this effect.
So remember there are
three possible mechanisms
that we wanted to explore
and one is maybe this is
just economic effects, right?
Maybe this is just migrants
are having a negative
impact only for example,
labor outcomes and we want to see
whether that there is some
evidence of that truly happening.
So the first thing is
exactly that checking
whether Venezuelan migration
has affected outcomes
in the formal or informal sector.
And for that, would we use
the labor force surveys
in Colombia and we basically tested
the main labor outcomes,
hours, work, wages
and unemployment in the
formal and informal sector.
And here I'm showing you the results.
It's a very similar
identification strategy.
And what we see overwhelmingly
is that whenever there
or in the municipalities
where there is a larger inflow
of Venezuelan migrants,
individuals, Colombia nationals
are working more they have
a larger unemployment rates.
And we also see some, let's
say suggestive evidence
that wages are dropping,
but it's not enough
to identify a statistically
significant effect.
So this is somehow saying, okay, yes,
there is something on
the economic environment
that might be driving voting behaviors.
And then we said, okay,
what else could be a main
important economic effect
that migrants
could have that may be
driving voting decisions?
And we thought another very important one
was a fiscal burden.
So in the sense that maybe
individuals are paying more taxes
or the government is sending
more money to those regions
that are actually receiving more migrants.
And for that, we use municipal data
on tax income per capita,
and the government transfers
from the central government
to the municipalities.
And we see evidences both.
So we do see that it seems
that at a per capita level,
individuals are actually paying more taxes
and also the central government
is sending more money
to these municipalities that
are receiving more migrants.
And so overall issue
resolved kind of give us
a very good understanding
that there's something going
on in the economic dimension
that might be driving voting effects.
So we cannot discourage, or discard
this socio-economic hypothesis
that this is very something
here at least in Colombia.
So the second hypothesis
was the cultural hypothesis,
which is very much in line with a question
that I just received
from Maria Teresa saying,
is it true that right-wing
ideologies are anti-immigrant?
And so for this part of the analysis,
we're not gonna be able to
offer a statistical analysis,
but we will kind of
talk to you why we think
or try to convince you why we think
this is not the main driver.
So the first thing is that
no, right-wing ideologists
in Colombia are not
typically anti-immigrant.
So in fact, the current
president of Colombia Iva Duque
is a very pro-immigrant president.
So he has been supporting
a very large amnesty
that has regularized Venezuelan migrants.
He has also given them
a very generous access
to social safety nets and recently
to unlimited health coverage
to any migrants in Colombia.
And I think this is an important
thing to take into account
because when we are kind
of ringing conclusions
from the north to the
south, we cannot translate
these right and left-wing
orientations in the same way.
So each country has their different views
or different political, let's
say agendas identifying left
and right and in Colombia
particularly right-wing
ideologies are not anti-immigrant.
Another important thing
to kind of mention here
why we do not think
this cultural hypothesis
could be driving our effects
is as Colombia-Venezuela
are culturally very similar.
So Colombians and
Venezuelans speak Spanish
and we were part of a same
country up until the 1831.
We or the very large vast
majority of Colombians Venezuelans
have the same religion, eat similar foods.
And so for all of these reasons,
it's really hard to envision
that the voting behaviors
or changing voting behaviors
are actually driven
by a cultural, let's
say xenophobic reaction.
But of course, this is not something
that we can prove it statistically.
And so the last mechanism that we wanted
to kind of bring forth is what we call
the electoral manipulation hypothesis.
And again, this is this
idea that the white
might be using the migration presence
or the large migration
flows to say, if you vote
for the left, we are going
to become the country
who actually expelled all
of it's migrants, right?
Or in other words, the right saying,
we're going to become Venezuela
if you vote for the left.
And I'm showing you just
hear some anecdotal evidence
of banners posted all across the country
in which there were
different messages suggesting
this idea saying, for example,
I don't want to leave us
a Venezuelan, if you
don't want to leave us
a Venezuelan vote for Duque
which was a right-wing
president candidate.
Vote for that Colombia, yeah. Sorry.
- [Mushfiq] I'm Mushfiq,
if I can just interrupt.
I'm just confused by
the word manipulation,
because manipulation sounds a lot stronger
than regular messaging, right?
Like almost like cheating.
That's not what you mean you just know
that they're changing their
messaging to take advantage of-
- Absolutely, I'm so sorry.
Yes, you're absolutely right.
Yeah. I haven't thought about that.
Yes, manipulation is, we're
not using this word to say
that this is illegal or cheating.
No, not at all.
It's just like a message
they are kind of using
their migration to kind of
send or increase the beliefs
that people have about the effects
that a left-wing government could have.
But you're right, we have
to think of a better name.
I haven't thought about that.
So that manipulation could
be misunderstood. All right.
So these are just a few of the
banners that we found online,
but this is widely publicized
all across Colombia
in the last presidential elections.
And then another thing
that I wanted to show you
was is it true that maybe
the majority of the voters
in Colombia have these fears
because maybe it's just a
minority or maybe they see
the banners that they don't believe it.
But here I'm just showing
you more, let's say anecdotal
or maybe some evidence of the fact
that there is a large
majority of Colombians
who actually think this is true.
So Invamer Marisa a statistical firm,
a firm that collect surveys in Colombia
and they do a survey
that is representative
of the majority of Colombian
voters, 96% of the voters.
It's not a representative
at the municipal level,
and this is why we can't use it
to run a statistical analysis
but at least we can kind of
try to see using the data
that is collected there
to answer this question.
Is it true that many
Colombians think this is true?
So the question that
is from us was Colombia
might be in the same
situation as Venezuela
in the near future.
Do you think that's true? Yes or no?
And you can see that the
green line would show you
the share of respondents
who actually thought
this was a possibility that Colombia
might be calming itself.
- [Attendee 2] This time I'm sorry,
let me make along the same lines
a bit more of a substantive point here.
- [Sandra] Yes, yes.
- [Attendee 2] It could be
that people have these belief,
it could even be that the beliefs
are correct or not, right?
That there's a certain
type of person coming
and their politics come with them right?
Now, regardless of whether
the beliefs are correct,
if the voters have the
beliefs, then you would see
that it might be actually sensible
in a political equilibrium
for one of the parties
or maybe even both of the parties, right?
To speak to those voters
and adjust their messaging
and targeting strategy in
order to like tell the voters,
yes, I mean, tell the voters
what they believe, right?
So for example, Fox News does a great job
of cornering the market
because not because Fox News
isn't making people believe something,
but because people already believe that
and they're happy to hear from someone
what they already believe innately, right?
Same thing with CNN on the left.
And so I think it's going to be, I mean,
when you talk about it
as a mechanism, right?
I think it's gonna be really
hard here to ever disentangle
the chicken and the egg problem, right?
Is it that voters believe
this and politicians
are responding or is it the politicians
are taking advantage of this
and making the voters believe that?
I mean, it's just a really
difficult problem to solve.
- Oh yeah. I totally agree with you.
They have probably go hand-in-hand.
What is very interesting, however,
is that this has never happened before.
It seems like they
appear at the same time.
This messaging and the fears
of Colombians have become,
and it's like, well, yeah, you're right.
Absolutely right, I totally agree with you
and I think that's something that we need
to tread very carefully
in our analysis about.
Thank you, Mushvick.
- Thank you.
- [Attendee 3] I'm sorry
to interrupt Sandra.
Would you be able to tell
us anything about the left,
is the left getting any
messaging along those lines,
are they responding-
- No , mostly silent.
Well, from what we've learned,
mostly silent about this.
It's almost like we just
say, no, that's not true,
that's not true, that's
the true, that's about it.
There's not really any
messaging concerning migration
either pro-migration or anti-migration
from the left in Colombia.
- [Attendee 3] Okay, thank you.
- They basically don't talk about it.
- Yeah.
And so one thing so because
we don't have perception,
let's say, or political attitudes say
at the municipal level,
one thing we did was, well,
why didn't we could find some measure
that could kind of
allow us to have a proxy
for how sensible or how
much each municipality
has been impacted by the left in the past.
So you might not know that
but Colombia was a country
that before the Venezuela migration
had a very strong internal conflict.
And let's say the
beginning of this conflict
was created by a leftist
group that was trying
to spark socialist
sentiments in the country.
And so oftentimes when you
talk to people at what you see
in Colombia is that the
armed conflict presence
is kind of viewed as
the presence of the left
in many of these regions in Colombia.
But of course, later on in the process,
that's something that I need
to be very upfront about.
Other groups appeared, which
were related with the right
but originally this conflict
was sparked by a leftist group.
So what we do in this
exercise is we try to evaluate
whether there are heterogeneous
effects on voting behaviors
for those municipalities
where the armed groups
had a very strong past presence.
So what we do is we create a
dummy that is equal to one.
If there was a very strong presence
of armed groups in that municipality.
And what we see is basically
that those municipalities
are going to have disproportionate impacts
of Venezuelan inflows in
the expected direction
basically reducing
support towards the left
and increasing it towards the right.
And another exercise, which
is very related to this one.
We tried to clean for the type of groups.
So there are many different
armed groups in Colombia
and the one who is mostly
associated with the left is FARC.
And so what we did here is
basically we created a dummy
to see whether those municipalities
that had a very intensified crisis
or where there was more FARC attacks.
If we see that those have
disproportionate impacts
of voting behaviors when
Venezuelans arrived.
And again, we see very, very strong effect
for those municipalities, again,
moving in the same direction.
Acute voter turnout and
a recomposition of votes
from the left to the right.
So although we can not prove
that this is what is going on here,
what we can say is there seems
to be a very high correlation
that these behaviors are
driven by municipalities
that have experienced first hand,
what could happen when
the left goes rogue.
And so we could be that in
these same municipalities,
the fears are very
strong about the effects
that other the left
could have in Colombia.
So to kind of wrap up my
presentation, what we observe here
is that the large migration
inflows from Venezuela
have had a very strong
effect on voting behaviors.
Specifically, we observe
more voters turnout
and a recomposition of
both from left to right.
We argue in our paper
and in this presentation
that there is no support for
the cultural hypothesis saying,
we don't see a very
strong case for the fact
that there is a resentment
towards Venezuelan
from Colombians, but
we do see some evidence
or some correlations that this effects
might be very related with
the effects that the migration
has had on labor outcomes or the fears
that Colombia might become a Venezuela
if they support the left.
But again, I think Mushvick
points is very bounding us
to we can really disentangle,
which is the chicken and the egg.
There might be things
that happen at the same
and are very, very strongly correlated.
Thank you very much.
- I think there was like, I
think more than a question,
what we have is that they said
that one of the participant
is saying that there
is a paper by Campante
and other authors showing
that politician use
the anti-immigration discourse
in the Ebola outbreak
context and they call
it strategic behavior
on that type of note.
- Super interesting. Yeah.
I can see how the fears of contagion
could also be used as an
anti-immigration argument.
Yeah.
- Yes, there isn't.
- [Jeremy] Hi.
So my question is the analysis
covers a pretty long period.
I'm wondering if have you
checked if results are different
when you restrict to migration
before the current crisis
and immigration after 2015
when the political discourse
may be quite different
surrounding immigration.
- Thank you Jeremy,
that's a great question.
So we tried to do that, but
unfortunately it's not possible
because let's say the discourse
from the right-wing
parties as to what we call
the electoral manipulation
coincide very, very dramatically
with the increasing Venezuelan
inflows in Colombia.
So when we restrict our
subtleties before 2016,
which is where this discourse
does not exist in Colombia,
Venezuelan migration was negligible.
So we're not able to really
identify any effects.
So we lose a lot of power in other words,
a lot of variation in the effects
that this might be causing.
- [Jeremy] Okay, so the
results are basically similar
if you were to just focus on the-
- Oh yeah, if we kind of
focused in the last period,
the results are very level
but when you lose the results
is when you move towards the past
when Venezuelan migration
was not as strong.
- [Jeremy] Thanks.
- Thank you.Peter.
- Yes.
I'd like to make a
comment on the beginning
and the end of your talk.
- Thank you.
- We started with the world
and generic way we ended
up with a great focus
on two South American countries
with cross border effects.
Now can we go back to the world?
How would you go back to the world now?
We see this everywhere what's happening
is what's common everywhere.
And is there something to be
brought up from a comparison
for the future what's
happening in the world.
Is it a popularism, is it a globalism?
What are people looking
for and can your analysis
and your methodology help thinking lead us
to help that people's think.
Now we're telling the world now.
Remember after World War
II the terrible effects
in Europe of the global wars it created
a certain determination
on the global level
so that refugee status is
available to anybody in the world
who was in danger of
death in his own country.
This is very important.
Where do we go from here?
- Yeah, yeah. Thank you, Peter.
A great question.
So I think the original
motivation of our paper
was to try to see whether the findings
that you had on developing
countries were translated
in a poor country or in a
country that has suffered
more dramatic inflows.
And we would just see, which
is similar across the world
is that you see that is
true also for this context
that whenever there is
a large migration flow
voting behavior shift in a
way that they support less
the right, sorry, more of
the right and less the left.
And you will see also that
do you see the same behaviors
in the Northern countries?
But what is very different
is that these behaviors
we argue are not predominantly driven
by anti-immigration
behaviors, but more for fears
of becoming the epicenter of crisis like
the ones they are serving.
And you would think that
this is only common about,
for example, Latin
America but in fact, no,
if you actually check what happened
in the last presidential
elections in the US,
there was a couple of very good articles
in the New York Times
recently kind of saying,
or suggesting that a
similar strategic behavior
was used by the Trump administration
to get the support of
Latino voters in Florida.
So this is not something that
is only happening in Colombia
and it's unrelated with
the rest of the world.
These type of strategic
behaviors could also be used
in the northern countries
to move Latin voters,
which are very important
to countries like the US
and that are sometimes can shift
the outcomes of an election.
And so in that sense, it
would be worth exploring
how important it was in the US.
I think that's actually a paper
that I would like to write
in the future to try to see
whether that was important
for determining the election
outcomes in Florida.
- Well, can I speak again?
- [Sandra] Yeah.
- After the second World War in Europe,
we had this whole idea
of certain unification,
but the most important thing
is cultural and (indistinct)
because governments humble
themselves by allowing
themselves to be taken to court
by individuals and stressed
that we have the European
Court of Human Rights.
Great effects.
Now in the United Nations,
the Commission on Human Rights
is simply an observatory.
There's no, I mean, people
in Russia just said,
naively used to think
in the days of communism
that you could take your
governments to court
the United Nations you can't.
But it may be that this
whole business of migration
is really bringing us to a situation
where the universal declaration
of human rights needs
to be supplemented by a
new universal declaration
of national rights.
This is a suggestion made by
Saint John Paul The Second
in 1995 at the General Assembly.
Now you're going to think
about this carefully
because you don't want dictators telling
the rest of the world dumped into fear
and what's happening in my country.
Why see such dictators oppress people?
So you'd have to have
the universal declaration
of national rights, which
in a way reflects Brexit
and Trump in a way and the
whole populism everywhere,
but then it needs to carry
within itself it's objection
to human rights or the United Nations
that would by citizens of your country.
- Thank you Peter. Super
thankful for your comments.
I definitely think that, but I agree
with some of the things
you were saying but I think
there are kind of different things
to what we're kind of
analyzing in this paper.
All we wanted to do in this
paper was to try to see
what are the impacts
that migration inflows
could have on voting behaviors
in a developing country
and explore what could
be driving those impacts.
So I guess that the sort
of more broad picture
that you're asking about
would be kind of subject
to a different paper or
probably a different analysis.
- We have a question by Wagner Oliveira.
- [Wagner] Okay, can you hear me?
- [Sandra] Yes.
- [Wagner] So Professor Sandra,
it was really great presentation,
very interesting paper.
I was wondering about the
mechanisms specifically,
those socioeconomic ones that you showed.
So I have two questions
concerning that the first one
is concerned with the
skill level of migrants.
If you have any information on that,
because I mean, there is some evidence
for the United States, for example,
that only low skilled
immigration led to voting
for the right and not high
skilled migration, for example.
So I was wondering if
you have some information
on skills of migrants compared to native,
and the second one
concerns the fiscal burden,
whether to show, like, I
think I saw that showed
both an effect on tax
revenue and transfers.
Can you see if there is
like some compensation
between the two of them?
I mean, what is the effect
on the budget of like,
if the government is
spending more relative
to what it's getting more
taxes, or can you see
that kind of information?
- Oh, thank you Wagner
both are great questions.
So on the skill. Oh, sorry.
Yeah. Okay.
So on the skill question,
there's two things
that I would say one is
that, as I said earlier,
I don't know if you'll recall, Venezuela
was a very prosperous country,
actually more so than Colombia.
So it turns out that
Venezuelans in general
are more educated than Colombian nationals
to the order of one to
two years of schooling.
However, as you've seen many
other conflict situations
or forced displacement
situations, this is not conflict,
but humanitarian crisis, the original
or the first migrants said
that we have in Colombia
at the beginning of
the humanitarian crisis
are very educated and very
wealthy and as the crisis
has progressed, we see
more and more vulnerable.
So we just, someone could
very much argue correctly
that the very last migrants
could be less educated
than Colombian nationals,
but if you kind of take
into consideration the
whole picture of migrants,
then on average they are more educated.
So it depends on when
you kind of do the cut
to measure that education level.
And on the second question, we
haven't done the net effect,
but this is a great point and
I think a great suggestion
to improve our paper.
Thank you.
- Yeah, thank you very much.
- Yeah.
- And we have a question by Martin.
- Yeah thank you.
I was just thinking about
the general liability
of the results.
It seems like it's very
key to this specific effect
that it's a left-wing ideology country
that people are fleeing
from and this seems similar
to the situation in Florida
with Cuban refugees there,
but it seems very different
from the kind of refugee inflows
that are coming into
Europe or within Europe.
And I was just thinking about
the framing of the paper,
if it's possible to
separate out kind of types
of refugee flows that are coming
because of a kind of natural disaster,
or at least where it doesn't
have a clear ideological
kind of connection and
refugee crisis that are coming
from a country whether it's
the very clear ideological
kind of cause to the crisis.
And also, I would expect the effect to go
in the opposite direction
if it had been a right-wing dictatorship
in Venezuela that caused people to flee,
like according to the mechanism
that you were pointing to,
we should see the opposite.
- Yeah, yeah, definitely great points.
So of course this would be
a different, more really,
I guess, cross country
analysis, but I definitely agree
with you that this is
very specific of the fact
that the crisis was brought
by a left-wing government.
And again, the same with
Florida with the Cuban regime.
It would be very interesting I think,
to do another research to see exactly
that whether depending on the ideology
that begins the crisis, whether
you see that the recipients
of those migration
flows we sent that party
that is specific political orientation.
And I guess that's a great
idea as you pointed out,
would be a blessed he with
testing for natural disasters
and see whether that drives any behaviors.
So yeah, I will be happy to write a paper
with you about that.
It sounded like a wonderful idea.
- Any more questions?
- [Jeremy] I have one more quick question.
So I know in some previous
work you've also done work
with internal migration and I'm wondering
if that's still a part of this research,
if you think there's something
you can learn by comparing
the effects of internal
migration with the effects
of international
migration because Colombia
has had so much internal migration.
- Yeah, Jeremy, that's a
great question. Thank you.
And yes, you're right.
Actually the very early
versions of these paper compared
both migration shocks.
So we were trying to see
whether the internal migration
had a different impact on
the Venezuelan migration,
because they were both very large shocks.
And very interestingly, we find
that the internal migration
had no effects on any of
the political orientation
or any voting outcomes in Colombia at all.
Nothing towards the left
or the right or the center.
What made it very
difficult for us to compare
both situations is that they
did not coincide in time.
So they are not contemporaneous.
So first we have the internal migration
and there was a political environment
and then we have the Venezuelan migration
and in both kind of take
place in different timeframes.
And so comparing them it's
complicated because of that.
But yeah, just to give you
an idea of what we found
when we tried to do that,
we did not find any impact.
- [Jeremy] That's interesting.
- And Sandra, so you were
mentioning that at the beginning
what you see are inflows of
people that are more educated,
does that have an effect on
the results that you have?
I mean, are you able to
pick that up from Campante.
- I see. Yeah.
So we unfortunately don't
have the data to know,
so where, for example, the
more educated individuals are.
So unfortunately Colombia
doesn't have a very good tracking system
to know where the Venezuelans are,
or if there is like a
stratification of location
by education levels in the country.
What I think most commonly happens
is that they tend to move to any place.
So wherever there is a very
large settlement of Venezuelans,
they will move, like the low educated
and the highly educated.
So it's really hard to tease out
then whether those locations
have differential effects
of both types of migrants.
But I know that there is a
largely (indistinct) suggesting
that the migrants that have
low education levels tend
to be direct substitutes
for low income individuals
and that creates sometimes more
resentment towards migrants.
And under is also kind of
mixed evidence on the fact
of what are the impacts that
highly educated migrants
could have on political views.
So when they bring money,
people tend to like them
and when they bring new
firms, new ideas, new assets,
people tend to like them,
but sometimes it's still,
they resent cultural differences.
And this is kind of what I
remember of the literature.
- Okay.
The other question, sorry,
is that you mentioned
about the unemployment,
so are the Venezuelans
also including these informal dimensions
that you have of informal work.
- Yeah.
- Do they have a permit to work,
which is normally the
case for other countries?
- True.
So the special case about
the developing countries
or the southern countries of the world
is that many of them have
very large informal sectors.
And it is true that in the
period that we examine,
not all of the Venezuelans
had job permits.
So in our analysis, we're
only kind of focusing
on the impacts on native.
So we only take into
account Colombia nationals.
But in general Venezuelans,
even if they don't have work permits
they might be working still
in the informal sector.
The informal sector is huge in Colombia,
like almost 40% of the economy.
And this is true for all
of developed countries
and so as such, even if the
government is restricting
their entry to the economy,
they will be very part of it,
a very, very active part of it.
They might not be able to
enter the formal sector
that's the only part where the government
might have some control.
But our analysis kind of
cleans them from the data.
There is some housing, labor
surveys directed to Venezuelans
but we are able to
identify them in the survey
so we can take them out.
- Apart from the academic
aspect of the paper,
seem very admirable.
I'm wondering if there's a drive,
there's an objective beyond
science in terms of influence
or culture because I think the science
isn't just for the sake of the science
has to be for the sake
of change and progress.
I'm wondering where do you go
from this kind of analysis?
- Right, I guess our
main drivers, of course,
beyond contribute to science
is to kind of by offering
or trying to understand how
migrants impact behaviors.
You may be able to presumably
at least bring an alert
to strategic behaviors that
might not be willing tension,
or that might be happening,
that people are not aware of.
And I think that's as much as I could say
in that direction right
now, like I think informing
and finding what are the
effects that migration
can have in a country and in
views and political attitudes,
it facilitates trying
to integrate migrants,
trying to help them be part of a society
and also kind of prevents
or brings an alarm
on to what type of behaviors are happening
that might prevent those
things from happening.
But of course, that's something
that we are not trying
to do with this paper.
This is just a purely
academic paper, just informing
of what are the impacts
that could be the motivation
for us as a researcher to
move this agenda forward.
- Good.
- Thank you.
- Very good. Thank you.
- Thank you very much, Professor Rozo
and yeah thank you Peter.
- Thank you.
- Thank you very much for your talk.
- Pleasure to be here. Thank
you for the invitation.